what am i one of my favorite takes I've
ever seen in film was William Holden's
in born yesterday when Judy Holliday
said to him are you one of them talkers
or would you like a little action this
year he's nominated for his talking and
his action in network here's William
Holden
when a film is finished shooting and the
captains and the Kings have departed the
film is left with a lonely person in a
small room you say what is his or her
job well it's to cut a film without
bleeding it to death and many a film
which started out shouting and full of
life on the soundstage died a thousand
deaths than in a thousand slices on the
cutting room floor and more importantly
many a film that looked as if it
wouldn't live through the night has been
saved by the tender mercies of a film
editor who knew just how to reverse and
juxtaposed footage so that the Beast
became a beauty but that doesn't begin
to tell you about film editors their
work is right before you
and like all obvious things invisible
now tonight the nominees for the film
editing award are Robert L wolf for all
the President's Men Robert Jones and
Pembroke J herring for Bound for Glory
Alan Hine for network
Richard Halsey and stop Conrad for Rocky
Eve Newman and Walter Hanuman for
two-minute warning
and the winner is are Richard Halsey and
Scott Conrad for Rocky
it's a wonderful moment for me and I'm
so happy to be able to share this moment
with Scott and when everybody out there
I'd especially like to come to thank
everyone for other contributions on
rocky special thanks to John and
Sylvester and to my friends and family
everything dick said is quite true and I
just like to say that it's really the
dream of a lifetime come true and thank
you very very much
you